we've got an incredible guest at the
desk she is a golden globe nominee for
her work in the hit musical series zoe's
extraordinary playlist and just in time
for the holiday season the whole cast is
back for an encore in the brand new tv
movie zoe's extraordinary christmas take
a look
you're reading my mind right now aren't
you you're reading mine and you
definitely don't want to do something
just the two of us
it's all
it's all really nice max truly
it's just
what
i don't want to not think about my dad
and be apart from my family for the
holidays it's not the course it doesn't
feel right i want us all to be together
and have the most mitch christmas ever
oh my goodness
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
i am so happy to be here i'm such a big
fan of both of you oh thank you so much
for coming and greeting us with your
presence and bringing holiday cheer
okay so zoe's extraordinary playlist
mega hit
golden globe nomination
people love the show
critical acclaim
it stops on nbc and then you guys get
together for this wonderful closure
i almost think that maybe this isn't
closure like maybe this is a thing that
can go on and on and on you hear it here
and we're starting first with
christmas
yeah
well this is all because of the fans uh
they were
so enthusiastic and unwavering in their
support for the show and then roku
picked us up so thank you so much but i
heard for this movie you only had like
four days to rehearse for all of the
dancing that is correct how did you do
it we just did it
that's what we had and yeah that's what
we did so you just drill it into your
mind and you're like we're gonna get
this yeah how
ah
i guess that's why they call it
extraordinary yeah
yeah well it is
congratulations with us absolutely
well jane it is your story all right
i've got a very hot topic okay and that
is re-gifting
so real simple says there's no shame in
the re-gifting game just because a gift
isn't right for you doesn't mean it's
not perfect for somebody else they even
suggest keeping a special drawer of
re-giftables all year long so you can
match them with the perfect person later
and tis the season to be sustainable and
this stuff
saves stuff from the landfill there's no
shame in re-gifting you know many people
have given me a candle thank you so much
but
i'm just one man so you know
they're they said at somebody's birthday
or the holiday something we run into
someone actually someone pops over oh
just for you but you the problem with
regifting is you do have to sell the
back story right and like i tend to
oversell it like um i panic like always
um i was at the mall and um i saw it and
it's pink and i know they're pink and so
i was like oh i'm gonna get a few drinks
anyway i hope you love it so you're a
re-gifter and a fiber totally
will lie to your face
jane how do you feel about re-gifting if
someone gives me a gift that i maybe
won't use maybe i already have a set of
headphones or something i think give it
to somebody but not as their birthday
present be like i was gifted this it's
just a random tuesday
and i can't use this and i love you so
take this but i think if it's like this
is your grand christmas present i
probably wouldn't regift in that way
okay now then i'm more with you because
i do if i get something
that
you're we're not digging up against you
rosie it's just a skosh all right and
finally we're celebrating hanukkah in
today's food news
now
jane um
my daughters are half jewish and we
celebrate hanukkah and christmas is it
true that you grew up the same way i did
yeah and if only you knew that what
we're about to eat is my favorite food
yeah okay well in the know
reports that the latest remix on the
lakka is the fried pickle vodka oh okay
i mean you had me at vodka and now you
have me even deeper with pickle it's a
traditional lot cut stuffed with a dill
pickle
okay this is my definition of heaven oh
my god this is a whole lot of flavor
that pickle is next level it gives it a
saltiness a brininess tang yeah like a
salty
starch
in a
creamy salt is just what i want to eat
at all times oh my god um
it's interesting how come pickles and
potatoes are not like the hot new couple
why are they not a thing um can i ask
you guys a question since um zoe's
extraordinary um christmas is coming out
um can each one of us recommend
a holiday movie oh i love that
i was more into spooky season so like
the nightmare before christmas was more
my vibe that's perfect okay um okay um
ross what about you
i'm i'm making myself watch holiday
classics i've never seen before like
miracle on 34th street never seen it
it's a wonderful life i've never seen it
what i know i know what i said i'm doing
the work okay
my uncle
lionel barrymore is potter in the
wheelchair okay i will know that
reference when i watch it my great uncle
is the villain
he's the bad man and it's a wonderful
life and he was in a wheelchair in real
life fun fact not a fun fact but i get
it well i yeah when i watch it i'll be
like oh hey uncle okay and then but i
think my favorite is a christmas story
the one that airs on tv all day long on
christmas day it's classic and it makes
me feel like it's christmas i'm gonna go
with planes trains and automobiles oh
wow every year
i love it so much it's the greatest
jane levy i'm so glad that you came to
eat latkes and talk hanukkah and
christmas and zoe's extraordinary
playlist and zoe's extraordinary
christmas and we can't wait to continue
to celebrate you thank you so much thank
you for being
[Applause]
1st here the fans are going to be lining
up
[Music]